foreign
Chad's with us in San Antonio hey Chad
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
um
so I'm a fairly new listener and
um recently I just took a traveling uh
job
and we we moved from Arizona and we we
travel throughout the country
um and who's we I'm
oh me and my wife okay she works remote
so she's able to work
um that sounds like an adventure cool
it's great so
um rather than staying in hotel rooms or
airbnbs or short-term rentals um we
decided to purchase we sold our home and
purchased a uh a travel trailer
so
um we have a note on that of
approximately seventy thousand dollars
and
um my question for you is do we let the
bank float up and continue to make
payments
or is paying something like that off
um a priority
we don't we don't have any kids um yeah
um no actually we I mean how much money
three to four thousand
I've got about 90 000 saved but we're
trying to have kids this year so I
haven't cost ninety thousand dollars to
have a kid either sell the trailer or
pay it off today
okay if you're not willing to pay it off
you need to sell it
the stupid thing's going down in value
like a rock
would you pay for it
uh 130 and you bought it new
yes sir you know what's going to be
worth in five years don't you
about what I owe on it yeah no
in five years it's worth 30. lower
you lost a hundred thousand dollars
over five years
that's what this did so if you're going
to keep it you got to pay it off
was it a smart option to do this other
than to stay in Airbnb I just felt like
that was throwing money out the out the
window I don't think it would have cost
you a hundred thousand dollars
because you're paying payments plus
losing a hundred thousand dollars
right
so no it was not it was not a smart move
but you're there now I'm not I mean you
know so here's the thing you're getting
ready to have kids sometimes you're
probably going to sell it and settle
down the sooner you sell it and settle
down
uh the less Financial damage you've got
so were I doing this over if you really
were bent on what you're doing I
probably would have bought the thirty
thousand dollar used one and towed it
around and let it turn into ten fifteen
thousand dollars and that would have
been much more palatable you bought a
freaking Bentley took behind your truck
130 Grand
our lifestyle we've been we've been
camping and traveling and and doing
off-road Sports so it kind of made sense
you're not even listening
if you well you lost a hundred and
thousand dollars Chad
that's what this just you overbought you
completely stepped in it and it's all
over your shoe and shaking your shoe at
me he's not gonna get it off
it's still there
oh my gosh so these trailers it's just
like with a car they're losing 60 of
their value within the first boats and
trailers go down faster than cars
and it's painful and RVs are the worst
they're the worst of the worst so
whatever you put into a boat a camper or
an RV you need to be able to set that
amount of money in the middle of the
floor and set fire to it and it'd be
okay because it's basically what you're
doing now I have a couple boats and the
same situation but I can afford to set
fire to that much money and it not
affect my life uh Chad can't afford to
lose a hundred thousand dollars so Chad
if I were in your shoes if you're gonna
keep it and I don't think you're going
to get rid of it based on talking to you
for two minutes you're probably going to
keep it because you're really sold out
on this whole idea uh I I would pay it
off at a minimum at least then you've
admitted what you've done and you feel
it okay and you don't have the payments
anymore so now we take the payments and
you start rebuilding your money so that
you can buy a home and settle when you
have kids because you're
um and the sooner you do that the less
this is going to go down in value
because I'm talking five years out that
130 is going to be worth 30. oh that's
painful
and uh so I mean that that's where we
are and and but if you if you sell it
now you probably can sell it for what
you owe on it yeah but uh but you're
probably gonna run this plan for a
little while longer I doubt one phone
call to Dave Ramsey's Gonna Change all
this so
um that that's the plan but yeah that's
what I would do if I were in your shoes
the good news is you have the money in
the account and you can pay it off
ouch
oh